lockdown in Kashmir protests over a
citizenship law in India coronavirus
outbreak just some of the recent events
to make headlines around the world but
how do they impact the global security
environment and what clues do they
provide to the direction some countries
take questions such as these are said to
be discussed at one of the world's most
well known and reputable security
conferences the Munich Security
Conference which gets underway today on
today's programme we look at India its
domestic debates and how that impacts
its ambitions on the world stage earlier
I spoke to summit Saran president of the
observer Research Foundation or ORF an
Indian think-tank headquartered in Delhi
mr. sarin thanks so much for making the
time now today India is marking the
one-year anniversary of the attack on
soldiers in Kashmir that prompted
retaliatory Indian air strikes in
Pakistan and is something that raised
tensions on either side of the border
how would you describe the current state
of india-pakistan relations
the airstrikes haven't necessarily
changed the longer view of the
relationship they have introduced a new
tactical dynamic I think Pakistan today
is far more cognizant of the fact that
asymmetric options that it had blatantly
been exercising over the past few
decades are perhaps going to have a cost
attached to it the Indian response tells
Pakistan that terrorist action has a
conventional response as a possibility
amongst various other options that India
has to it it introduces a new tactical
uncertainty for Pakistan whether that
hold is something that time will tell
but I do believe that it was an
important moment in introducing a new
normal between the two but then after
that you had the special autonomy of
Kashmir that was withdrawn and that
further raised tension there was a
downgrading of diplomatic ties was that
necessary has that contributed to a
worsening of ties you know history will
be a good judge of that action I believe
something needed to be done in Kashmir
we could not have allowed it to continue
down the same path as it had in the past
you know 7 decades some government had
to create a new format for engagement
integrating the people with India this
government decided this was the best way
to do it I think you have critiques and
you have supporters but let me put it
this way they got some of the elements
right they are struggling with some
other elements and isn't the struggle
generally for a larger Kashmir policy it
appears that the government is generally
focusing on the military option and they
can't really be I think is gently agreed
in Indian circles that they can't really
be a military option to that so what is
this government's Kashmiri strategy no I
think the political and muscular option
has already been exercised you have put
together a constitutional and a physical
presence that integrates the state to
India now it's time for the development
and the economic tools to be deployed
and for them to be successful and
efficient you are not going to have
political success on
you have an economic social cultural
integration so I think that is the work
in progress and that is where the
government has to be far more creative
and innovative that is something that is
going to test this government like it
has each other government in the past
would you say that this is also
contributing to a general anti Pakistan
sentiment that is potentially working in
the current government's favor in terms
of a domestic agenda the anti Pakistan
sentiment is perhaps both underplayed
and overstated I think that really the
the nature of our birth as two countries
in 1947 have introduced a certain and
once to this particular relationship and
those most affected continue to see each
other through those times I suspect that
this government's popularity will be
based more on its economic policies in
the days ahead based on what it does in
terms of providing development and
political stability and reviving the
Indian economy I think they are going to
be judged on entirely different matrix
of performance outcomes then foreign
policy or what they do with Pakistan
alright let's look at the Munich
Security Conference where one of the
themes this time round is the concept of
West lessness a slow decline if you like
of the Western led order that has been
in place after the end of the Second
World War
now if that decline accelerates would
you say in Asia India comes in to fill
that gap or is it China
I don't think India is an All India is
dependent India's significance in the
future is dependent on either the decay
of the West or the rise of China I think
India as one-sixth of humanity will play
a significant role any which ways now to
just spin your question a little bit
further I would argue that this is a
good moment you know we are going
through a silly season across the world
we are having debates on citizenship on
borders on sovereignty on
multilateralism on populism and this is
these are secular debates happening
everywhere I think this is the time for
new powers to stake claim towards
leadership in fact unabashedly let me
put forward a new book that Jessie and I
have written dr. Shashi Tharoor and I
put forward as its title the New World
Disorder and the Indian imperative and
we argue that based on our largely
liberal traditions are largely
market-based economics are the plural
and argumentative democracy it is
perhaps time for new actors like India
to add their hef to the liberal order
which may not remain that liberal if
India was not to be a part of that and
it certainly is not going to be Western
in as the Asian century progresses now
that Western element will have to be
replaced by certain new Eastern liberal
ideas and India is best placed and best
suited to do that so I don't think it's
restlessness but it's going to be West
and the East that will have to come up
with a template that is far more
applicable to the Asian century then to
one that was obsessed with the Atlantic
and that Lanting citizens but one final
question you talked about liberal order
how liberal is India currently I mean is
India wearing its earlier badge of
honour as being a liberal tolerant
democracy with pride the way it used to
earlier or has that changed a bit well
to me India is varying it's a matter of
being a democracy quite nobly I think
every Indian debate is there for the
world to hear and participate in we are
using the ballot boxes to express our
opinions on key questions the Indian
route to have evolution and not
revolutions seems to be still holding of
course there is polarization of course
there is discontent of course there are
those who are dejected but let me be
very clear I think last week you saw
when the incumbent in New Delhi was able
to retain a seat where the central
government the ruling party had made a
determined bit to upstage him you have
also seen the ruling party lose two
previous elections and you are going to
see them do well in other elections I
think Indian democracy is using the
ballot and it's vote to determine its
political project and therefore India
should continue to be this fine
exception in that particular part of the
world where ballots over bullets have
always determined its political cause
some ways are unpleasant of
thank you so much